nothing strikes fear in the heart of
humans more than the thought of a great
white shark even writing this video gave
me some extreme bouts of queasiness in
our modern comfortable life we almost
never have to think about being hunted
ripped apart and eaten but looking into
the eyes of a great white shark any
comfort we might have felt gets ripped
away deaths from great white sharks are
not unheard of and I know many people
who won't step foot into the ocean
because because of this intense and
primal fear but with this Primal Fear
comes a morbid fascination with one of
the most formidable Predators the world
has ever seen these monstrous fish can
reach up to 20 ft or 6 M long and can
weigh up
2,270 kg or 5,000 lb their rows of
coarsely serrated sharply pointed teeth
are built to tear through flesh and
shatter bone it's it's no wonder that
Hollywood can't resist portraying them
as crazed and indiscriminate Hunters
attacking people boats and anything else
at random ripping off arms and legs just
for fun and while great whites do
sometimes kill humans their attacks are
not random and in fact form unexpected
patterns in space and time their kills
are purposeful and ritualistic and most
of the advice we've heard about how to
avoid a great white shark attack isn't
necessarily true great white sharks are
so much more than brutal killers they
are sophisticated Elusive and smart
animals they have extremely sharp vision
and the keenest sense of smell of any
shark and maybe of any animal in the
ocean and scientists are realizing that
they may be far more intelligent and
delicate than we give them credit for so
much so that aquariums the world over
have notoriously failed to keep them in
captivity hundreds of experts and
millions of dollars in resources have
not been enough to crack the code of how
to keep them in man-made tanks but as
much as we've learned about their
biology great white sharks continue to
surprise and baffle the scientific world
just how powerful is a great white shark
and how does it decide what it's going
to attack and what it's going to eat and
what about great white sharks makes them
unable to survive living in
captivity
[Music]
great white sharks are enormous fish
with a body shaped like a blunt torpedo
with a sharply pointed conical snout
large pectoral and Dorsal fins and a
strong crescent-shaped tail they have a
dark gray coloration on their back and
sides and only their belly is white they
were given their name from the days when
they were only observed by Whalers who
saw the whites of their bellies while
the sharks feasted on the whales the
humans were trying to harvest which they
often do upside down enabling this
nashing and tearing are the white shark
serrated triangular teeth the points are
for puncturing the serrations for
ripping around 50 teeth are exposed in
in use lined up in rows at the top and
bottom of the mouth but Behind These
rows are six more rows of teeth each at
a different stage of development unlike
humans whose teeth are set into the bone
shark teeth are set into the gun s and
while grabbing and subduing thrashing
prey many of these teeth fall out thus
the shark needs to replace them often
the teeth and the extra rows in the back
will move forward as the teeth in the
front are lost a great white shark will
go through around 30,000 teeth in its
lifetime the outer part of a great white
shark's tooth is made up of hard and
mineral Rich analid which is similar to
the enamel on our teeth and is made up
of fluorapatite a mix of fluoride and
calcium bonded together fluorapatite is
a very hard mineral so these teeth can
withstand the crushing Force when biting
prey and this crushing force is one of
the strongest in the animal kingdom in
2008 a team of scientists conducted an
experiment to determine the great white
shark bite force using three-dimensional
computer analysis of their jaw mechanics
and while only theoretical their
findings indicated that the largest
white shark could exert a bite force of
over 18,000 Newtons if their analysis is
correct it would mean the great white
shark has the second most powerful bite
of any living animal after only the Orca
however the saltwater crocodile is
another contender in the mix for top
bite force and has actually had its bite
force directly measured at
16,40 Newtons But whichever animal is on
top it's actually surprising that great
white sharks are a contender at all
because their skeleton including their
jaw structure is made entirely of
somewhat rubbery cartilage this
cartilage is several orders of magnitude
less stiff than bone this perhaps
prevents the bite force of great whites
from being even higher but for however
much their cartilage skeleton May hold
them back from an even stronger bite it
makes up for in their Locomotion
cartilage is strong and dense but it's
not as heavy as bone so it reduces the
weight sharks making it easier for them
to swim at faster speeds with less
energy being expelled and it's clear
that they are top swimmers they can swim
as fast as 50 kmph or 35 mph and have
been known to migrate long distances
from Hawaii to California and from South
Africa to Australia their speed and
endurance is thanks to their unique and
surprising musculature generally fish
have two types of muscle fibers white
and red red muscle fibers are aerobic
and sustain constant swimming whereas
white muscles are anerobic and are
primarily used for short bursts of Power
with their huge migrations you might
expect a great white shark to therefore
have tons of red muscle but it's
actually the opposite great white shark
muscle is comprised of over 90% white
muscle fiber this gives them an
unparalleled ability to accelerate
quickly while hunting ambushing their
prey at high speeds but what about their
long-distance travel how does such a low
percentage of red muscle work for this
unlike other fish whose red muscle
fibers are situated just under the skin
the red muscle fibers of great white
sharks are located deep in the body the
thickest part of the red muscle is also
located near the dorsal fin which is the
thickest part of the body this again
seems to not make sense at first if the
purpose of this muscle is sustained
swimming why is it so far from the tail
and close to the bending axis as
counterintuitive as it might seem this
placement of the red muscle allows for
very efficient motion and is what gives
the great white shark its swimming style
called thundor swimming thunderform
swimming generates power through the
coddle fin rather than whole body
undulation compare this to the swimming
used by other fish these types of
movement move the whole body which would
be less efficient at High speeds but
even with a buoyant skeleton and
efficient Locomotion all this activity
in fairly cold water might seem
surprising considering most fish
including most sharks are ectotherms
that have a lower body temperature and
move slower eat less and grow slower but
when scientists started to measure the
internal temperature of great white
sharks they found something unexpected
they placed one thermometer inside a
shark's stomach and one on the outside
of the shark to read the ambient water
temperature and they found that even
when the water temperature fluctuated
and was quite cold the shark's stomach
temperature stayed at around 26.2 de C
this could only mean one thing that the
great white shark was regulating its
body temperature it is now understood
that these sharks have an adaptation
called Regional endothermy this is a
type of warm-bloodedness that allows the
shark to keep its critical regions like
its swimming muscles stomach and Rin
warm this does a few things for the
shark it allows them to live in much
colder water dive much deeper move much
faster and it might even be the reason
they are so enormous by unlocking a
broader Niche and being able to hunt
faster larger animals Regional
endothermy may have been the thing to
promote the true competitive superiority
of great white sharks but with this
endothermy comes a cost great white
sharks are among the most energy
demanding fish meaning they need to eat
a lot to stay alive which brings us to
the next question how does a shark
decide what to attack and
when we've all heard certain advice
about how to avoid shark attacks don't
swim at dawn or Dusk and whatever you do
don't bleed in the water and we've all
heard explanations as to why Surfers get
bit that great white sharks have poor
vision and mistake Surfers for sea lions
or Turtles and if you're getting
attacked punch it in the eye as best you
can but really only some of this is true
because what really motivates a great
white shark attack is different from
everything we've been told and the
reality of it has been revealed by
Decades of research in one specific and
spectacular geographic location the
Falon Islands in Northern California
these islands are a rich feeding ground
for great whites and though it's only 30
Mi west of San Francisco Surfers and
swimmers know to stay far away seals and
sea lions are abundant here and these
are a great white's favorite prey the
first thing the researchers stationed on
the islands noticed was that great white
sharks hunted during daylight hours
which is different from how most other
sharks hunt so the argument that
avoiding swimming at dawn or dusk will
prevent a great white shark from taking
a nibble on you is not exactly helpful
though might still be smart for other
reasons at first this surprised
scientists for a long time sharks were
thought to have poor vision with a
grainy and monochromatic view of the
world enabled by what scientists thought
was exclusively rods in their eyes rods
are useful for detecting contrast and
movement and animals who live in
lowlight settings have an abundance of
them cones on the other hand discern
detail and require a well-lit
environment and for a while these were
believed to not exist in sharks but in
1985 scientists realized that the white
shark does have cones and that their rod
to Cone ratio was different from that of
almost any other shark the moderately
deep dwelling smooth Dogfish has a rod
to Cone ratio of about 100 to1 the more
shallow water lemon shark has a ratio of
about 12:1 but in the white shark the
rod to Cone ratio is about 4 to 1 great
whites hunt in the daytime because they
have excellent color vision and are
primarily visual Hunters but this is not
to say that white sharks can only see
during the day just like cats and other
nocturnal animals you see when you shine
your flashlight in the woods at night
sharks have a reflective layer behind
their retina called the tapetum lucidum
this structure greatly increases the
photos sensitivity of the eyes in low
light conditions so much so that great
whites can likely see By Starlight alone
and this brings us to the next myth
about great white sharks that they
mistake Surfers for turtles or sea lions
but with their excellent Vision a great
white likely knows with certainty when
it's got a prey animal like a sea lion
in its field of view so why do sharks
sometimes attack humans and how do they
choose what to attack and what to eat at
all the researchers at the Falon Islands
got a glimpse of this when on their
watch a commercial scuba diver was
attacked by a great white 200 M from
Shore the shark swam up from underneath
seized him carried him pulled him down
for several seconds and then suddenly
let him go and swam off the man was
severely injured but survived this
pattern is similar to other great white
shark attacks on humans they bite but
then they release but why don't sharks
want to eat us we seem like an easy
enough Target a hint emerges by looking
at other animals sharks attack but don't
eat the researchers at the Falon Islands
noticed in one instance a shark seized a
brown pelican totally mangled it and
disabled it however the shark just left
it there to die and never ate it they've
also noticed dozens of dead sea otters
that wash up on shore intact but with
fragments of great white shark teeth
embedded in them what is the connection
between humans pelicans and sea otters
we are all mostly made of muscle whereas
the preferred prey of great white sharks
like seals and whales are mostly
composed of fat we've already
established that great whites are very
energy demanding fish because of their
endothermic nature but to be so picky as
to totally abandon muscly meals for
fatty ones seems extreme but it turns
out they need fatty meals for more than
just their energy demanding metabolism
and movement they need all that energy
to grow and grow fast adult white sharks
increase their body length by more than
5% per year this growth rate is three
times higher than the moo shark another
large predatory shark from the same
family so when a great white nibbles on
a human it's simply gaining information
about whether you have enough blubber to
be worth their while and for the animals
that are worth a great white shark's
while well that really sucks for them
because the way a great white shark
hunts is actually more horrific than I
ever quite realized and it's a little
different depending on which prey it's
going after fair warning this is where
the queasiness might set in when a great
white shark attacks a sea lion it
usually starts with an explosive Splash
this initial strike often takes a chunk
out of the sea lion but sometimes it is
able to escape the researchers at the
Falon Islands recorded 75% of sea lions
surviving the initial strike but their
escape is temporary the white shark will
chase down the injured animal and
recapture them it takes another bite but
then lets it Go the animal will slowly
bleed out and die later its body will
float to the surface and only then will
the shark eat it a great white's
approach with a seal is slightly
different the first bite that's so
explosive when hunting a sea lion is
usually invisible when hunting a seal it
happens under the water the way
researchers identify a seal attack is a
large Blood Stained area of water then
the blood stain elongates indicating the
shark is carrying the seal sometimes
great distances underwater once the seal
is no longer bleeding the shark will
allow it to float to the surface and
only then will the shark eat it both of
these methods of hunting appear to be
almost ritualistic biting releasing
dragging and most notably of all
exsanguinating in almost every instance
the researchers observed the the cause
of death of the prey animal was blood
loss and the Sharks seem to always wait
sometimes for quite a while for nearly
all the blood to be gone researchers
don't fully understand why they do this
but their best guess is that the shark
doesn't want to eat prey that is still
thrashing because they don't want to get
any injuries so they let their prey die
a slow death and wait to make sure they
are super dead before eating the most
heinous method of murder all because the
Sharks don't to get any boo boos but
great white shark rituals go even
further revealing that great whites May
in fact be capable of communicating with
each other to a remarkable degree once a
shark kills a prey animal like a seal it
often floats at the surface for a while
before being eaten but if there are
multiple sharks in the area they are all
going to want that tasty meal and the
decision of who gets to eat it is
decided in a surprising ritual the
Sharks don't fight over the the food
instead they participate in a
threatening display of tail slapping at
the surface splashing in the direction
of the other sharks as many times and as
forcefully as possible the shark who
manages more tail slaps is the winner
it's surprising that an animal so
formidable wouldn't just fight over the
prey but this sort of holds up with
their other Behavior they really are boo
boo avoidant but when the boo boos in
question are having your face spit off
by your opponent it makes sense that
great white sharks would evolve a less
violent but still dominance-based way to
communicate and claim prey and this
backs up one of the main pieces of
advice we get if a shark is attacking
you to punch them in the face these
murder guys are kind of delicate and
many Surfers and divers have reported
that a biting shark left them alone
after a strong Boop to the snoot and as
much as I'm joking around about this
great whites really are pretty sensitive
a jab to the face probably does really
hurt them due to tons of nerve endings
and sensitive tissue there and though
delicate these tissues are what make the
Sharks such Keen hunters in particular
their nose is the source of their
Electro reception abilities if you look
closely this area is full of tiny little
black dots these are pores called ampl
of laurenzini filled with an
electrically conductive jelly the
bottoms of the pores are lined with
hairlike cells called cyia these cyia
respond to changes in nearby electrical
currents transported by the jelly which
trigger nerves in the shark's brain
which tells them something alive is near
by but this Electro sensory ability only
works from about 1 M away while the
shark is locking onto its Target in the
final moments before attack to sense
prey at longer distances they use their
incredibly acute sense of smell great
white sharks have the largest olfactory
bulb among sharks its relative mass
compared to the rest of of its brain is
18% and a keen sense of smell makes
sense when you consider how stinky a
great white's preferred prey is if
you've ever been to a beach or a pier
where sea lions are hanging out you'll
know what I mean odors from stinky sea
lions or decaying whale carcasses create
scent trails that are carried by the
tides and the currents sharks might be
able to follow these trails with great
Precision a huge benefit if a blubbery
meal is the reward but the claim that a
great white shark can smell a drop of
your blood from a mile away the jury's
still out on this one I can't find a
single reputable source that has done an
experiment that tests how far away a
great white shark can smell a drop of
blood I personally still wouldn't jump
into the ocean with an open wound but if
you get a scratch while surfing you
probably don't need to worry about it
for so many reasons we don't need to
worry about great white shark attacks at
all great whites are simply not the
maneaters they they've been portrayed to
be we can see how risk avoidant they are
how much they don't want to get injured
how they communicate gently they are
complex and sensitive animals and our
attempts to force them into a box
figuratively and also quite literally
has only done them
harm the first aquarium to attempt
holding a great white shark was marine
land of the Pacific in
1955 and the shark died in less than 24
hours when they tried again in 1960 the
shark barely made it 2 days but this
failer isn't unique to marine land for
decades multiple aquariums attempted to
hold great white sharks in their display
tanks marine land of Florida SeaWorld of
San Diego the steinhart aquarium and
other aquariums all tried holding great
white sharks but they either died or had
to be released what was going on if so
many facilities failed to keep great
white sharks alive for more than a few
days clearly something about captivity
just doesn't work for these animals
researchers have speculated about a
couple of possible causes first the
Sharks might have been ill before they
were even captured in some cases they've
been hooked by fishing nets immediately
before being transported to an aquarium
and if a great white shark isn't
constantly swimming it can't get enough
oxygen and is on borrowed time another
hypothesis is that their Electro
reception skill interferes with their
ability to sense the glass of the tank
meaning they're constantly bashing into
the walls these sharks are also used to
traveling vast distances and being stuck
in even a large tank is still a huge
shift in their ability to roam far and
wide they're also used to hunting live
food not eating dead fish handouts the
mree Bay Aquarium therefore decided to
take a different approach
from 2004 to 2011 they brought in only
young of the Year white sharks the
scientific term for fish that haven't
yet reached one year of age over that
period of time they brought six sharks
into captivity four did fairly well and
remained on display between 70 and 198
days so what went right and what went
wrong for these young sharks first there
was their size and age the Sharks ranged
in size from 137 to 164 cm and weighed
between 25 and 47 kg much smaller than
full grown adults they were also
transported in stages first they were
brought to a deep ocean pen off Malibu
to allow them to recover from the stress
of being captured they stayed in the
ocean pen for 10 to 25 days or until
they started feeding regularly again and
were deemed healthy enough for transport
from the pen they were moved into a
transport tank on a ride that lasted
between 5 and 7 and 1/2 hours once they
arrived at Monterey Bay Aquarium they
were placed in the 3.8 million L outer
bay exhibit that holds pelagic fishes
like blue fin and yellow fin Tunas as
well as other shark species the four
sharks who did do well in captivity ate
regularly and were fed on a diet of fish
like Pacific mackerel but two of them
started displaying predatory behavior
during the final weeks on display
one shark fatally attacked two soupin
sharks and they both chased scalloped
hammerhead sharks and galpagos sharks no
surprise both these sharks were released
when they started chomping on the other
animals in the exhibit but what about
the two sharks who didn't do well one
just never fed regularly so staff
released it after 11 days the other fed
somewhat regularly but also started
bumping into the walls of the enclosure
it showed signs of developing an
infection ction and stopped eating so
the montre Bay Aquarium released it
after 55 days of captivity and fitted it
with a tag unfortunately the tag showed
it died almost immediately the
researchers never recovered its body so
an autopsy wasn't possible but they
speculated that its death could have
been caused by an attack from a large
predator or from an injury when the
acoustic tag was being implanted the
third possible cause of death is a
mouthful but as the report reads an
irreversible Cascade of metabolic
aberration associated with an acidbase
imbalance caused by the cumulative
effects of extraction from exhibit
transport to Southern California
pre-release handling sampling tagging
and transport to the actual release
location in other words being brought
into captivity is what triggered its
death imagine being a huge Predator with
the entire ocean at your disposal then
suddenly you're yed out by some hairless
Apes put in a weird moving tank then
dropped in a larger but still limited
tank if there's anything surprising here
it's that the Monterey Bay Aquarium
succeeded in holding these animals in
captivity for any length of time from
start to finish the biology of great
white sharks shows us that it is not us
who need to fear the Sharks but the
other way around I definitely still
don't want to take on a great white in a
1 V one battle but it's not hard to see
that despite our lack of terrifying jaws
of death we really are the animal in the
world that holds all the power great
white sharks are delicate sophisticated
animals who deserve as much reverence
and respect as any of the charismatic
ocean animals we all care so much about
and when it comes to the chances of
being bit there's a lot of stats
floating around out there some say a
person's chance of getting attacked by a
great white shark is 1 in 11.5 million
others say it's one in 40,000 there are
a lot of different calculations going on
here what's the real number
the answer lies in an understanding of
probability and surprisingly there's a
free and easy way to learn about exactly
this on brilliant brilliant is the best
way to learn math data science and
computer science interactively and they
have a brand new course called intro to
probability which teaches you to analyze
real world data to calculate the
probability of many different kinds of
events There are 16 lessons that will
allow you to understand probability by
manipulating visually Iz ations to
understand the likelihood of different
scenarios I love the interactivity of
this the sliders and buttons that allow
me to test my understanding as I go
along this is so much more engaging and
so much more effective for me than rigid
textbooks and classroom settings with
what I learned on brilliant and after
doing some more digging I came to
understand the shark statistics a bit
better the one in 40,000 chance of being
bitten by a great white comes from data
about people engaging in a specific
activity in a specific place people
doing offshore surf Sports off the
southern coast of Australia the 1 in
11.5 million stat comes from a different
subset of people people who go to the
beach in the United States these are
very different scenarios and thus very
different numbers by digging into the
data behind the stats we see thrown
around all the time we can avoid being
freaked out and instead just get to the
truth brilliant has thousands of lessons
like this from foundational and advanced
math to AI data science neural networks
and more that will help you learn about
topics that we hear about all the time
but may not fully understand it's a
great way to become educated about the
world in a very real and very meaningful
way so to better learn how to
confidently navigate this world of
overwhelming numbers and to try
everything brilliant has to offer free
for a full 30 days visit brilliant.org
/re science or click on the link in the
description the first 200 people will
get 20% off brilliant's annual premium
subscription and every sign up helps
this
channel